[Music]
here we go again sony has once again
revealed the free games for ps plus
subscribers for the month of december
2021 as per usual you can grab all these
games from the first tuesday of the
month which this time is all the way
over on december the 7th
first up on the ps5 is good fall a
visually striking yet kind of mundane
hack and slash adventure if you like
collecting loot you will like godfall
which also supports three-player
cooperative play without a doubt the
best element of godfall is the combat
with countless weapons to master
including a hammer a broadsword and even
dual blades there is some finesse to
each weapon such as using heavy attacks
to fill up a stagger gauge to knock back
your enemy and another system which
buffs your secondary weapon over time
pushing you to switch your play style
and use other weapon types the problem
was when this game released button
bashing could pretty much get you just
as far as being a skilled fighter but
that was over a year ago now the story
sees us fill the boots of a king in
exile who must hunt down his own brother
who wants to be a god that loot we
mentioned becomes a thing you'll chase
when the story dies down and there's
tons of it including 12 sets of top tier
armor which buffs your play styles in
different ways if you are a
completionist gamer godfall ticks so
many boxes but you must also expect to
play the same missions over and over and
over again next up we have mortal shell
if you like from soft games like dark
souls sekuro and bloodborne you'll very
much enjoy mortal shell but also if
you've ever been intrigued to play dark
souls but was a bit put off by how
difficult it was then mortal shell is
the perfect starting point and that is
simply because it's less difficult and
far more forgiving we have fast light
attacks strong but slow heavy attacks
and a very forgiving dodge mortal shell
also has a hardened ability which turns
your character into stone so you can
tank a shot from the enemy this one
ability turns excruciatingly tough boss
fights into a much easier affair but by
lowering that skill ceiling mortal shell
never feels as monumental as the games
it's based upon we play as a being who
cannot survive in this world and must
find a corpse to resurrect hence the
name mortal shell there are four shells
to discover all warriors with immense
fighting abilities that change your play
style so will you give mortal shell a
try and finally a much less punishing
game lego dc super villains the first
thing of note here is that the story is
surprisingly good and i mean it the
justice league has vanished leaving
behind a group of imposters known as the
justice syndicate and they're all voiced
by really talented actors lego dc super
villains lets us design and become our
own super villain upgrading our powers
as we progress through the story or if
you don't fancy being original you can
play as pretty much any dc super villain
that comes to mind all of this is in a
fully open world with countless easter
eggs and references to the dc world and
many standout locations to visit too
like metropolis and gotham lego dc super
villains is totally a kid's game but
nobody has to know that you're an adult
play what you like and on top of all
this remember there are three more psvr
games which you can still get for
another month and did you know one of
those the persistence can be played
without psvr so add it to your library
if you haven't already so that's our jam
for the month of december 2021 what are
your thoughts please review the
offerings in the comments below i'm adam
you're awesome merry chrysler
[Music]
you